a University of Virginia student is due
to be arraigned on murder charges later
today after Sunday night's terrible
shooting on a Campus bus returning from
a trip to Washington D.C three young men
died that night all of them UVA football
players the suspect used to be on the
team two other students were also
wounded senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herod spoke to
the mother of one of those players
Sunday
was one of the worst days
of my life Brenda Holland's son Mike is
a running back for the UVA football team
she says the night of the shooting she
felt restless and uneasy what do you put
that down to by connecting with my baby
my connection you felt something was
wrong felt something shots were fired on
Sunday night as this bus pulled into a
campus garage at the end of a field trip
an eyewitness said the alleged shooter
of former UVA football player 22 year
old Christopher Darnell Jones Jr was on
board what I'm hearing is Mike made it
off the bus
but went back to help his friends and
was shot he was shot in the back exited
through his stomach Holland said Mike
was very close to the three players
killed Sunday Devin Chandler Lavelle
Davis Jr and especially to Sean Perry
seeing
Mike without DeSean was unheard of
Poland said her son is using pen and
paper to ask about his friends he can't
talk but he has written
desean's name he has written Devin's
name and then I believe it was an L does
he know those players are dead no
no
we can't
despite her anger Holland said she's
praying for the suspect and his family I
pray for them and I'm working through
forgiveness
because we have to we have to forgive
for CBS mornings Catherine Herridge
Charlottesville Virginia
we're all praying for them I mean it's
such a horrible story so glad her son is
alive still fighting for his life but I
can't stop thinking we keep talking
about these families that are still
grieving right before Thanksgiving there
is no good time but this is just such a
heartbreaking no and they're at school
they're living their family's dream you
try to get your kid into college onto a
big big time football team and we still
don't know the motive still don't we
don't know more